- All right, man,
what's up, man?
It's Vandaveon again.
- It's my boy Mike back here.
- What's up?
- Straight up, man,
"Key & Peele," dawg.
Y'all still doing it, man.
Y'all still getting it going
for real, man.
I like this, man.
Show is good, dawg.
- Niggas stupid, though.
- Man, we had another problem
with a couple
of them scenes, dawg.
Trying to help you all out,
you know what I'm saying?
- Got to hire us, man.
- He should be the head writer,
man, I'm telling you.
He be getting the biggest laughs
at the airport.
- Straight up.
- Straight up, man.
You had this one sketch, man,
where y'all was talking
about the Indian dude,
and he was a doctor
and whatnot,
and the other dude was crackin'
and clowin' on his shit.
Man, watch this, dawg.
- I know this is
hard to hear,
but we need to make
some serious decisions
about your mother's health.
Let's be honest.
She is getting on in years.
- Oh...snap.
Okay, I see how it is,
I see how it is.
Well, yo mamma so old,
her last name is "Asaurus."
[laughter]
- Go ahead!
- [laughing]
That was my shit.
- But it was stupid, though.
- I'ma tell you, man,
seriously, though,
to make it funnier,
y'all should have been--
you should have utilized
the Indian dude more, man.
- Indian dude.
- That's some funny shit
that y'all missed, man.
- Punjab,
Punjab and shit.
- This nigga...
[laughing]
Talking about Punjab.
His name should have been
Punjab Slumdog.
- Yeah.
- [laughing]
- That's some shit.
- That was Mike's idea, man.
That was Mike's idea.
And then, what you should
have done, man,
is, y'all should have had him,
like, go into his filing cabinet
or something like that.
He should have opened up his
filing cabinet and been like,
"Oh, here's some of my
Indian food I'm about to eat.
"Sha-kow.
I'm gonna eat this Indian food
while we have this meeting."
- Vindaloo.
- Vindaloo, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He should be eating some
vindaloo, just be like this.
And the whole time
these niggas was talking,
he should have been like,
"Mm, this food is good.
You black guys,
this food is good."
[makes fart sound]
- This nigga talking about.
[laughs]
- That's what
he should have done.
Nigga should have just
eaten his food,
talking about,
oh, oh,
"Your momma is sick."
- [laughs]
- "Your momma is sick."
[makes fart sound]
- Tikka masala, nigga.
Tikka masala, nigga,
tikka masala.
tikka--
- "Hey, excuse me, I'm gonna eat
my chicken masala."
- Tikka masala, nigga.
- Nigga, I said it, I said it!
I'm gonna eat my shit
right now.
Mm, this food is good.
Your momma is overweight.
Squeeps.
[laughter]
That is my shit, right there!
That's my shit!
And then you be like, "Man."
And then the other dude
could be talking about,
"Hey, man, I don't understand
what's wrong with this room.
"Man, this room
is stanky as hell.
Is your damn food stinking,
or is your fart stinking?"
- Nigga is stupid,
this nigga is stupid.
- Y'all should write this down.
- That food--that food
smell like farts
sometimes, though, too.
- It do, man.
It do be smelling like farts.
And then the doctor
be talking about,
like, the doctor should get,
like, a prescription
that's funny.
He should be like, "If you want
your momma to be better,
you need to put a dot
on her head."
- Nigga stupid.
This nigga stupid.
[chuckling]
- Home run, right there, man.
- Why you be stupid,
nigga?
- "Why don't you put a dot
on her head,
"you black guy?
You black guy."
[laughter]
That would make that shit funny!
- Nigga stupid.
- We done, motherfucker,
we done!
We got to be done, man.
- This nigga stupid on this one.
- That's a home run.